hey youtubers is Charlie and in my
Suicide Squad review I asked you to
submit all of your questions so I picked
10 of them to answer in this video with
one bonus question so much to talk about
Harley Quinn the finale and season 3 the
through-line in this episode and
something I think that's gonna play into
the finale was that line a bad man
turned good just remember that whenever
you're thinking about the big villains
from this season if you're finding me
for the first time I do arrow and flash
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything and feel free to leave
me suggestions for future videos you
want to see me do so let's answer some
questions careful for spoilers if you're
not cut up on the episode yet number one
comes from Zee music 2013 do you think
that shrapnel blowing up is like a
grundy thing where they will end up
returning looking more like they do in
the comics so Marc Guggenheim explained
that they killed shrapnel in the episode
just to convey the idea that the Suicide
Squad members are expendable that
doesn't mean that he couldn't totally
come back in a future episode but we're
supposed to think that he's dead don't
plan on seeing him again for the rest of
this season but until you see someone's
cold body on a table they are not
confirmed dead and if they ever
introduce weirder powers in the show
like magic or the Lazarus Pit
death will essentially become
meaningless which is why they haven't
done stuff like that yet but I am hoping
to see someone literally come back from
the dead this season you know Coulson
style question number 2 BD destro asks
do you think that Deathstroke and Merlyn
are working together no I think Merlin's
involvement is purely tied to Thea if
there's any Slade crossover it'll be
coincidental Merlyn is such a big
character though I would be totally
disappointed if he doesn't fight Slade
at some point Merlyn wants to protect
Thea Slade wants to destroy Oliver
family it only stands to reason that at
some point Merlyn will end up fighting
Slade with Oliver or helping Oliver in
some way remember the theme of the
episode a bad man turned good I actually
think that that's foreshadowing for
Merlyn and Slade's character this season
question number 3 digidestined asks do
you think that Slade could be Roy's
father and that's why he survived the
serum that is an awesome theory here's
actually what the comic books say about
Roy's father though his history has been
retconned a few times his father that is
but for a while he was a wealthy
businessman who died in a plane crash on
an island leaving Roy stranded it's kind
of like Oliver's father died in the boat
crash leaving Oliver stranded on the
island another time
Roy's father was said to be a scientist
who died when one of his experiments
exploded which kind of mirrors the dr.
Ivo plot you know even though I've oh
isn't confirmed dead yet
so you can actually tie Roy two
characters that already exist on the
show but I think those are just
coincidences I think that Roy survived
just because he's special like Slade and
Oliver I think Oliver totally would have
survived the mirakuru
if Ivo had dosed him with it it is fun
to think about
arrows having this Empire Strikes Back
storyline though Deathstroke is Darth
Vader with the mask and he tries to turn
Roy to the dark side by revealing he can
give him what he wants more than Oliver
can I just like the idea that
Deathstroke Empire Strikes Back that
would make a great spin-off question
number four lunatic reason asks they
mentioned markovia again anyone want to
see the outsiders like I do they should
do the season with Green Arrow traveling
the world on the hunt or Slade Rex Mason
in Egypt katana and Japan geo force in
markovia and so on so that's actually a
really nice idea and as season 3
progresses I think you'll definitely see
arrow tell more international stories
the universe is always expanding just as
Neil deGrasse Tyson and Carl Sagan most
of the time though they don't do stories
like that just because they have to
focus on building Starling city stories
which is what this season's Deathstroke
a story has been all about smaller plots
like The Suicide Squad you know have to
balance service of that at a certain
point so they can't just jump from
superhero - a superhero all over the
place all the time but next season
you'll definitely see even more Suicide
Squad more travel and more new secondary
characters a lot of those new characters
will probably be shared with the flash
TV show just because DC and Warner
Brothers is trying to create this
unified universe just like Marvel's
trying to do with its movies and TV show
question number 5 Thomas McCain asks in
the last scene with Sarah and Oliver in
the episode when Oliver takes Sarah's
hand did anyone else get a marriage
proposal vibe so that's actually a
really nice theory and if anyone's not
familiar with the comics here's some
background on their relationship there
was a certain point several years ago
where Green Arrow and black Canary got
married the show has been shipping them
really hard this season and I've seen a
lot of evidence to suggest that caity
lotz will be back
next season but there hasn't been any
confirmation so destro could still
totally kill her I'm hoping he just
kills Moira you know not that I hate her
I just love Caity Lotz so much and just
to hammer that idea home someone is
going to die this season if the canary
survives through the finale you know
then doing a marriage storyline would be
an awesome cliffhanger for season three
and it would give Oliver's character an
interesting place to go emotionally
remember how he said the felicity that
he has to keep everyone at arm's length
you know just to protect them what would
happen if he ever got married to someone
Sara said that she's not that girl on
the island anymore so it's possible that
they want us to think that she's strong
enough as a character to withstand being
in a long-term relationship with him
being married to a superhero is not all
fun and games there is a lot of punching
and kicking question number six rope
Yanis asks who would be your picks for a
Teen Titans spinoff so off the top of my
head I would say cyborg
Ravager Jericho and Roy I don't know how
they do Beast Boy Starfire or Raven at
this point just because we haven't seen
those types of powers on a live-action
show yet and Superboy is just a whole
messy copyright issue I think in season
3 what we're gonna see is a mini Teen
Titans s story like Roy and sin and some
other characters will get a side story
that Oliver isn't a part of that'll be
the closest thing to a live-action Teen
Titans we'll see if it goes well I'm
sure they'll totally develop it for a
pilot someday question number 7 Jim
Moriarty asks how do you think that the
Suicide Squad will be part of the final
fight with Deathstroke so yes they're
actually gonna be part of the final
fight that's the whole last scene with
Amanda Waller was about they're
basically gonna use them whenever Oliver
finally goes after Slade to do battle
episode 18 is called Deathstroke so it
could either come then or in one of the
final episodes shrapnel is that for all
intents and purposes so either it will
just be bronze Tiger Deadshot Diggle and
Lyla
or they'll add another villain like
Merlin or Huntress I'm not expecting any
other new comic characters outside of
Rachel Ghul and the two flash people
killer frost and vibe but I don't think
that any of them are actually gonna join
the Suicide Squad
it's a really interesting thing though
is is that I don't think that that final
fight is going to be the final fight of
the season
I think Rachel Ghul will come and Slade
will end up having to work with Oliver
at least temporary
I don't think they don't stop being a
bad guy but it'll be just like Deadshot
working with Diggle there's still
self-serving villains but they just team
up with the heroes briefly in this case
Slade and Oliver will probably have to
work together to deal with racial Ghul
after he comes at least that's if Manu
Bennett comments on the arrival of
Rachel Google are to be believed we'll
have to see how it actually ends up
going down but just remember that theme
a bad man turned good question number 8
Jose Beltran asks do you think the Barry
Allen will be present for the fight was
Slade so no Marc Guggenheim confirmed
that Barry Allen will still be in a coma
whenever this is happening he won't wake
up till the pilot episode of the flash
so that's why those other flash
characters are cameo in episode 20
that's killer frost and vibe but we have
no idea what they're doing in Starling
city question number 9 HG drifter asks
do you think we'll actually get Oracle
or will Felicity fill her role in the
birds of prey episode so Felicity is
actually going to fill the role of
Oracle I think you know because the
character is wheelchair-bound we're all
kind of worried for her safety Hera is
just gonna change things a little bit so
she can become that Oracle character
without getting our spine broken it's
just like the Suicide Squad episode
they're gonna be slowly developing the
birds of prey as a thing on arrow so
there will be more Huntress Canary and
Felicity team-ups in season 3 think of
next week's episode is like the
beginning of that they totally will not
be best friends whenever they start out
though they'll be developing that trio
relationship over time question number
101 movie games asks in episode 19 it's
called under the hood do you think that
that could mean Red Hood or is it just a
play on words so it actually means a
couple of things but none of them have
anything to do with the Red Hood first
it's actually a reference to someone
else finding out Oliver's true identity
probably detective Lance or Laurel the
second meaning is Roy his arsenal red
arrow persona will be developing more
the episode right after that episode 20
is called seeing red so I think that
will mostly continue the Roy red arrow
plot he's supposed to get his official
costume this season so it could be
coming in that episode and one last
bonus question LA prodigy asks do you
think that the arrow flash universe will
ever be part of the Batman Superman
movie universe I definitely think
they're trying to make that happen as
much as possible Warner Brothers did
have
for Nolan overseeing their DC Comics
properties like joss whedon is doing for
Marvel if you're not familiar joss
whedon isn't just directing the Avengers
movies
he's like the creative director for the
Marvel Universe that means that he steps
in to all the movies and TV shows and
talks with the writers and the directors
to make sure everything blends with
everything else they're trying to do
that's why it seems so organized I don't
think that Christopher Nolan is doing
that for DC and Warner Brothers anymore
but if he's not then someone else is I
know Geoff Johns is highly involved with
the creative aspects of the TV shows and
development so short answer yes they are
all connected but asterisk you know not
as much as Marvel's universe is
connected so thank you so much for
submitting your questions guys these
videos are always a ton of fun to do
I'll be doing my birds-of-prey video
next week be sure to subscribe to get
that I'll also try and get another bonus
flash video out soon too right now click
here for my Suicide Squad review and
click here to learn more about the flash
TV show thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you